for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy
okay so last but certainly not least the
amino acids or are the amino acids
decorated to oxaloacetate how many of
those are there there are two asparagine
and aspartate so basically asparagine
can give aspartic they're very similar
in structure the difference is really
what's going on with this this amide
group versus a carboxylate group so what
happens there is a reaction analogous to
the glutamine ace reaction shouldn't
hydrolyze off that ammonium ion via
asparagine ace pretty much the same as
the glutamine ace enzyme for glutamine
to glutamate and then the aspartate
undergoes a transamination reaction a
simple transamination reaction catalyzed
by aspartate aminotransferase to give
oxaloacetate which of course can go to
the TCA cycle okay and that about wraps
it up I hope that all was helpful thank
you for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying